das ist die wichtigste neuerscheinung
des jahres ist das wichtigste buch was
ich bisher in diesem jahr gelesen hat
wahnsinnig großartig literarisch so
großartig großartig jetzt ist es mehrere
monate her dass ich das buch gelesen
habe und das beschäftigt mich immer noch
für mich ist es das wichtigste buch weil
jenseits von allen bezügen und von allen
politischen aktualitäten transportiert
ist eine botschaft die ich zeitlos finde
nämlich du bist verantwortlich für dein
leben du hast die pflicht aufzustehen
und die verhältnisse zu ändern denn
sonst macht es nämlich keiner
das buch spielt eigentlich nur an einem
einzigen tag es ist der vierzehnte
geburtstag eines jungen namens john
grimes der von seiner familie gedrängt
wird sich als laienprediger zu betätigen
und wir erleben diesen gottesdienst
genau dieses buch erzählt abwechselnd
die geschichten derer die dort
versammelten
mitten in diesen menschen und kann ihre
wahrnehmungen ihre gefühle ihre
ambivalenzen so darstellen dass man auch
als leser mitten drin ist und plötzlich
universen aufgehen es gibt eine stelle
in dem buch da wird sein richtiger vater
nur aufgrund seiner hautfarbe
festgenommen weil er zufällig als
schwarzer auf dem bahnsteig steht wo
auch verbrecher stehen es ist ein buch
was 953 erschienen ist das heißt es ist
interessant wie aktuell man das immer
noch ließ es ist völlig legitim und
richtig finde ich ihn dass er jetzt
wieder auch im zusammenhang mit der
neuen schwarzen bürgerrechtsbewegung
wieder so diskutiert wird es wird ja
auch gezeigt wie die abgrenzung die die
gesellschaft aufgrund der hautfarbe
entgegenbringt zum teil internalisiert
wird und das passiert natürlich in
diesen kleinsten zusammenhängen und das
macht er großartig ist es gibt ja keine
schwarz-weiß schilderungen in diesem
buch selbst figuren die zunächst
fürchterlich erscheinen wie dieser
stiefvater werden ja noch in ihrer
ambivalenz gezeigt es ist eine
bildreiche sprache irrsinnig kraftvoll
es wird immer beschrieben wie jenen
menschen auch schwitzen und wie das
licht sie plötzlich schal aussehen lässt
richtig handfest verschwinde ich in der
schilderung auch der physischen existenz
das ist sprachlich tatsächlich so ein
gospelsong die übersetzerin steppen und
hat ihre deutsche übersetzung nach
gesteppt damit es den rhythmus bekommt
denen dieses buch auch braucht also es
hat wirklich so ein schema was sehr
stark
indem sie eine musikalisch geprägt dass
nicolas steiner ließ das buch noch mal
und ich weise währenddessen darauf hin
dass bereits der nachfolgeband
erschienen ist den ich hier nicht nur
deswegen in die kamera halte weil er ein
quote von mir vorne auf dem cover
ja allerdings da ich habe es geschafft
nicola handlich bewundernswert und
zeitlos gültig wir brauchen baldwin es
perspektive ja das kann ich ja nur und
das ist doch ein schönes schlusswort wir
brauchen beides perspektive